[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 nuestra historia
de hoy nos lleva hasta Colombia y es que
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos estudia el caso de Janet
valderrama una mujer colombiana
campesina que fue rociada con glifosato
en el año
1998 durante las aspersiones ordenadas
por el gobierno
Janet estaba embarazada con su tercer
bebé y producto del contacto con esta
sustancias tuvo un aborto y seis meses
después falleció en un hospital por una
falla multisistémica durante casi 25
años su esposo Iván y sus dos hijas han
pedido una justicia que todavía no ha
llegado además el estado colombiano
vulneró la maternidad deseada la salud y
la vida de Janette y la conversación
sobre esta historia es con Catalina
Martínez quien es la directora regional
para América Latina y el Caribe del
centro de derechos reproductivos y
también con Cristina Rosero aseso
legales de la misma organización gracias
a ambas por estar en ellas hoy Muchas
gracias Ángela por habernos invitado y
por visibilizar este importante caso un
caso que además es doloroso y duro y a
propósito de eso pues vamos a empezar
contando la manera que ustedes han
elegido para difundirlo y para que la
gente tenga conciencia de los verdaderos
efectos del glifosato en mis manos tengo
la novela gráfica que se creó
especialmente para esta ocasión y se
llama una lucha por la vida glifosato y
daños a la salud reproductiva Y es que
bueno este caso es bastante particular
Catalina y Cristina porque es la primera
vez que muerte por glifosato es la
denominación que llega hasta esta
instancia para ser evaluada y quiero
empezar preguntándoles en qué va el
proceso porque esta es una familia que
está padeciendo este tema desde 1998 son
ya casi 24 años desde el fallecimiento
de Janet y su hijo y todavía no hay
respuesta favorable
Claro que sí Ángela bueno el caso de
Janet valderrama como tú muy bien lo
dijiste está ante la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos esta
petición se presentó en el año 2008 por
Conde abogados quienes han acompañado a
la familia desde el inicio digamos del
caso y en el año 2018 la comisión admite
el caso pasan 10 años entre que se
presenta el caso y finalmente tenemos
una admisión este tiempo que transcurre
digamos que se debe también a que la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos recibe los casos de
vulneraciones de derechos humanos de
todo el continente y dentro de estos
digamos llega el caso de Janet en este
momento el caso está en una etapa muy
avanzada una etapa que se llama la etapa
de fondo en donde la Comisión
Interamericana está evaluando las
vulneraciones de Derechos Humanos que se
cometieron en este caso así que estamos
esperando Ojalá una decisión por parte
de la Comisión Interamericana Ojalá en
el siguiente año Esta es la historia de
un yo soy un padre que vivía en una zona
apartada de Colombia una zona sin acceso
a centros de salud que tuvo que viajar
muchas horas para que su esposa fuera
atendida a pesar de esto no se pudo
detener este aborto que se produjo
después que tuvo que desplazarse a
varios municipios y ciudades de Colombia
para buscar atención para su esposa que
lentamente fue cediendo ante una falla
multisistémica que no se entendió jamás
y que aún hoy sigue en la impunidad y
que se explica después del contacto con
esta sustancia tanto Iván como miles de
campesinos colombianos hoy exigen que se
limpie su nombre Porque en medio de esta
estrategia de lucha contra las drogas
que ha sido auspiciada por Estados
Unidos aún hoy por qué y les pregunto a
ustedes se ASUME que la población rural
está compuesta por este duro término de
narcoterroristas cocaleros bueno
básicamente también este es el resultado
de una política de drogas que no ha
estado de cara las necesidades del país
ni tampoco ha entendido
las necesidades de la población en las
zonas Rurales el caso de Don Iván lo
ilustra perfectamente porque es una
persona que no se dedicaba al cultivo de
la hoja de coca y que aún así sufrió los
efectos de esta política y que fue
juzgado como si fuera un cocalero Y ese
es un punto importante porque por una
parte el estado en esas zonas no
aparecía a través de una escuela o a
través de un hospital sino que apareció
únicamente mediante las avionetas que
aspejaban el glifosato y que los
expusieron a graves daños tanto a su
salud como a su vida Pero además el
hecho de que las entidades no
respondieron de manera adecuada los
llamados de Justicia por parte de Don
Iván cuando él acudió a la justicia
penal administrativa las respuestas
fueron que el estado no tenía una
responsabilidad y precisamente eso le
obliga a llegar a instancias
internacionales bueno Y además de esto
pues tenemos aquí un componente muy
importante y es el enfoque mujer Este es
un dolorosísimo ejemplo de violación de
los derechos sexuales y reproductivos de
las mujeres colombianas el estado no
solamente no los garanti sino que
tampoco activó medidas de protección ni
de reparación Para Janet ni para su
familia esta mujer tenía Apenas 27 años
hablemos hablemos sobre esto sí Ángela
es muy importante este caso precisamente
porque es el primer caso primero que
llega la Comisión Interamericana sobre
este tema pero segundo que efectivamente
visibiliza ese enfoque de género y
transversal de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos porque cada vez que
hablábamos de los daños que producía el
glifosato en la salud humana en la vida
humana o inclusive en el medio ambiente
no habíamos tenido este lente de género
verdad Y ahorita lo que estamos viendo
con el caso de Janet es como las
aspersiones de glifosato tuvieron un
impacto
diferencial en las mujeres quienes por
ejemplo sufrían abortos involuntarios
como es el caso de Janet valderrama no
como una maternidad deseada se vio
afectada por una política de aspersión
de glifosato en el país y y el caso de
Janet valderrama lo ilustra muy bien
pero adicional a eso con junto con la
Universidad del valle el centro derecho
reproductivos hizo un informe que le
entregamos a la comisión de la verdad en
donde también quedaron registrados todos
los daños digamos que se pueden sufrir a
la salud reproductiva humana al estar
expuesto a glifosato no solamente
abortos involuntarios también
esterilidad e inclusive afectaciones en
el feto y en las segundas generaciones
de una familia preocupa mucho más
Cristina que la historia de Iván
finalmente a pesar de todas las demoras
de las décadas que han pasado por fin
está siendo escuchada tardíamente Pero
qué pasa con esos otros miles qué pasa
con los que se quedan por fuera del
registro que no tienen como en su
momento Iván las posibilidades de un
rápido y eficaz acceso a la justicia sí
hay que Resaltar que el caso de Janet no
es un caso excepcional existen reportes
en numerosos lugares de muchas mujeres
que perdieron sus embarazos y que hubo
otros a la salud reproductiva con
ocasión de estas aspersiones pero no
necesariamente estos daños son conocidos
por el país y precisamente visibilizar
el caso de Janet permite poner sobre el
radar lo que ocurrió con esta política
Por otra parte También es importante que
se piense en Cuáles son todas esas
dimensiones de los daños que se
ocurrieron con este programa Aquí por
ejemplo es muy importante Resaltar las
recomendaciones de la comisión de la
verdad que al ver el caso de Janet como
un caso emblemático declaró en su
informe final que por una parte debía
investigarse Cuáles habían sido las
dimensiones de esos impactos Incluyendo
los abortos espontáneos debe hacerse
mesas participativas con las víctimas
para establecer medidas de reparación y
lo que es más importante dejar Claro que
nunca más debería retomarse una política
de aspersión con glifosato sino que ir
por otras medidas como las que están
contempladas en el acuerdo de paz frente
a la sustitución voluntaria de cultivos
claro y ahí estamos hablando de estas
recomendaciones que entrega la comisión
de la verdad en un contexto de un país
que está viviendo un conflicto de un
país que trata de transitar Los caminos
de la paz y que además ha tenido un
cambio histórico Y es que en este
momento transita también por su primer
gobierno Nacional de izquierda en la
historia y con ese precedente Pues yo
quiero preguntarles a ustedes Cómo ven
la perspectiva de este caso y del caso
de otras víctimas creen que podría
cambiar el enfoque de acercamiento y de
reparación bueno consideramos que el
caso de Janet es un caso que es muy
importante y va a ser muy importante una
vez decidido por la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
primero porque va a ser el momento para
que la familia de Doña Janet
efectivamente puede hacer reparada y
alcance la justicia que ha estado
buscando durante tantos años pero
segundo porque la comisión va a poder
emitir una recomendación es generales
para que este estos casos no se vuelvan
a repetir no Y nosotras creemos que van
a ir muy en la línea de lo que la
comisión de la verdad ya dijo a nivel
nacional entre por ejemplo que nunca se
vuelvan a las aspersiones de glifosato y
esto lo va a dejar muy claro la comisión
estoy segura en su informe sobre el caso
y esta recomendación no sólo va a
aplicar para Colombia sino que va a
aplicar para todos los países de la
región que han reconocido la competencia
de la corte Entonces vamos a tener una
decisión de alcance regional adicional a
eso ya situandome en Colombia con el
gobierno actual creemos que hay altas
posibilidades de que efectivamente se
acate la decisión de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
Sabiendo además que es un gobierno que
ha replicado reiteradamente que no va a
retomar las aspersiones de glifosato en
el país entonces Esperamos que no solo
no la retome sino que además se
comprometa en identificar los daños y en
repararlos aquí de lo que se trata es de
dignificar a las víctimas de dignificar
a las personas que han sufrido y que
necesitan urgentemente que la justicia
llegue y estas víctimas lo que quieren
es continuar con su vida y recibir
respuestas pero ustedes como
representantes Pues están llamadas a
hablarnos de la activa de lo que les
espera Y es que por poner un ejemplo hay
otra historia muy emblemática y es la de
Doris salape que también llegó a las
cidh su caso viene de 1999 hay esperanza
en este tema en una justicia que tarda
toda una vida en llegar para un caso tan
específico como es el de la muerte de
una mujer por glifosato
sin duda Ya de por sí una justicia que
ha llegado tarde difícilmente va a
reparar completamente a las personas que
han sufrido este tipo de daños sin
embargo precisamente por eso es urgente
que haya un pronunciamiento y que nos
permita a partir de allí transitar hacia
una reparaciones que son más que
merecidas por una serie de víctimas en
todo el país Entonces el caso de Janet
que tomó 24 años y que todavía nos está
tomando para poder llegar a una decisión
nos muestra cómo es esa búsqueda de
Justicia tan difícil y como muchas
personas presentaron quejas pero nunca
recibieron una respuesta en el caso de
Colombia hay más de 17.600 quejas
relacionadas con ocasionadas por el
glifosato pero que más del 96% ni
siquiera fueron aceptadas ni evaluadas
de fondo esto significa que hay un gran
vacío de justicia y Esperamos que tanto
la recomendación es de la comisión de la
verdad como en la decisión del caso de
Janet puedan sentar las bases para
lograr esa reparaciones Más allá del
caso específico y sin embargo
potencialmente nos enfrentamos a muchos
años más de litigio o de que se decidan
los procesos al lugar para saber
finalmente en qué queda el caso de
Yolanda valderrama ahora ya para
finalizar el glifosato sigue siendo una
discusión constante en países como
Colombia pese a su evidente peligro Pese
a que se incumplen las normativas de
aspersión y Bueno aquí para pues
nuestros televidentes estas aspersiones
deben ser a una cierta altura para que
solamente afecten en teoría estos
cultivos y este terreno accidentado de
Colombia no lo permite y hace que las
aspersiones se hagan más alto y pues
esto por supuesto pone más en riesgo la
vida de las personas Al hacer que estas
sustancias pues se Esparza en el
territorio
está sobre la mesa que podría ser usado
nuevamente al parecer no por este
gobierno sin embargo
dará este caso un precedente para
fortalecer esa idea de que el glifosato
debe ser prohibido Sin lugar a dudas va
a dar un precedente para reconocer la
responsabilidad Estatal al de
violaciones de Derechos Humanos Al haber
usado indiscriminadamente el glifosato y
haber afectado la vida salud salud
reproductiva de millones de personas en
el país pero adicional a eso es ya una
decisión de obligatorio cumplimiento
para el Estado colombiano entonces sin
lugar a dudas va a representar un
presente muy importante y Esperamos que
así sea y sobra que también estaremos
atentos a los desarrollos que se den en
la comisión sobre sobre sobre las
reparaciones a las que tenga lugar
Gracias a ustedes por estar con nosotros
gracias a nuestros televidentes y nos
vemos Próximamente en ellas hoy